Film Courage: What suggestions do you have
for screenwriters on developing a character?
Evan Kidd, Filmmaker/Podcaster: I think you
need to know what your character needs to
achieve in your broader story.
You also need to think Okay, what would happen
if I spent time with this character?
I always think of it that way.
Anytime I am writing a character, developing
a character I think if me and this character
went out to get a drink at a bar or something,
what would we talk about?
How would the conversation flow?
Would he be doing the talking?
Would I be doing the talking?
Would it be balanced/not balanced?
Would they leave after five minutes because
they have something to do?
I would always try to think about the broader
world a character inhabits outside of just
the script because for me that influences
a lot of the character’s decisions and things
that they’ll make later in the script I’m
writing.
And I always when I develop try to do like
a word cloud if you will for a character.
So I try to think if you just met this person
for five minutes at the grocery story, you’ve
never seen them before, what would your first
couple of takeaways be?
I always try to list those off.
Then I think Okay what would maybe their mom
say about them, someone who has known them
for ever and ever?
So I have these two different word bubbles
and it’s always like about balancing what
is their kind of quick takeaways from a quick
appearance versus the deep down stuff that
they don’t let out.
Film Courage: That’s really cool.
Is this [the word cloud] something you got
from a book that you read or you just came
up with it?
Evan: It might be from a book.
I’ve just kind of have done it recently
in the last couple of years.
I don’t think I could call it my own formula
but it seems to work for me.
It’s kind of a fun way to role play a little
bit with character to think Okay what would
they do?
How would they do things in a different way
versus like this person is mad all the time
because…and this person is happy because…You
are able to live in the world and world build
a little bit further that way (at least just
internally as a writer).
Film Courage: That would actually make a cool
app?
You just put someone’s photo and in 2 minutes
it populates what someone’s mom would say
about them and then what someone would say
about them in the grocery store.
Evan: Yeah!
I like the thought of a time limit on it because
then it forces you to be very rapid fire with
quick takeaways.
I love that!